صحوه الناس في امريكا ما الجديد في هذا
الحركه في هذا البرنامج بنحرص على التعريف
بالجماعات الفكريه والسياسيه وهذا التعريف
ليس محصورا بالعالم العربي والاسلامي
وجماعته بل بالعلم كله خاصه اذا كانت
الجماعه اللي بنتحدث عنها جماعه جديده
وذات اثر عالمي عبر الحدود
عنها في حلقتنا اليوم وهي الجماعه وين شئت
قلت الحركه تعرف باللغه الانجليزيه
هل هي حركه ام جماعه سيكون جزءا من نقاشنا
اليوم مع ضيفنا وبسبب حداثه نشات هذه
الحركه اختلف الباحثون والمتابعون حول
التعريف العربي الدقيق لها لكن
بالانجليزيه تمت اضافه كلمه روك في اهم
قواميس اللغه الانجليزيه في العام 2017
فعرفها قاموس اكسفورد انجليزي كصفه
ومعناها الاصلي مطلع بشكل جيد او محدث
ومتجدد يعني اب تو دايت اما في الاستخدام
اليومي وبشكل رئيسي كما جاء في القاموس
فتعني الصحوه واليقظه والوعي بالتمييز
العنصري او الاجتماع والظلم كذلك كان
تعريف قاموس مريم وبستر الامريكي حول كلمه
مشابهه وجاءت بمعنى مدرك ومبادر بفاعليه
في القضايا المهمه خاصه قضايا العداله
الاجتماعيه والعراقيه بينما نشر قاموس
اللغه العاميه تعريفها قبل عامين من
القاموس الرسمي وعرفه بالوعي بما يجري في
المجتمع فيما يتعلق بالعنصريه والظلم
الاجتماعي وبمعنى اخر ان يكون الفرد
متيقظا للقضايا الاجتماعيه الحساسه
واعطائها الاولويه للنظال من اجل العداله
الاجتماعيه ورغم ما ذهبت اليه قواميس
اللغه الانجليزيه مؤخرا في تعريفها لكلمه
ووك الا ان الكلمه مرت بمدلولات مختلفه
متحورات الى معان متعدده واستخدامات
مختلفه تبعا للحقبه الزمنيه التي اعيد
بعثها بها حتى اصبحت اليوم كلمه استيقظت
تعني بايجاز
الايديولوجيا السياسيه اليسريه التقدميه
وظهر معها ما يعرف به
وكلتشر
لكن يبقى الاهم من الخلاف على المصطلحات
التوقف عند البرنامج الفكري والسياسي
لحركه الصحوه او حركه الاستيقاظ ولماذا
نحن نتحدث عنها اليوم في مساحه اعلاميه
عربيه بينما هذه الحركه تنشط في الجزء
الغربي من الارض في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يشار الى ان هذه الحركه وبحسب
مناصرها هي المعبر الحقيقي عن جيل الالفيه
بالعالم الباحث عن الهدف والمعانه في ظل
عالم السوشل ميديا المطرب فما هذه الحركه
وما الجديد فيها ومن هم رموزها وما
مستخبرها انا هدى الصالح وهذا برنامج
جماعه للتعرف على هذه الحركه الصحوه او
اليقظه معنى اليوم الدكتور برنارد هيكل
استاذ في دراسات الشرق الادنى ومدير
المعهد الاقليمي للدراسات المعاصره حول
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا واسيا الوسطى
في جامعه برنستن حياك الله دكتور
احواك بدايه ظهوره
بصراحه هذه الحركه همم يعني بدت همم في
السنوات الاخيره هذه يعني من ثلاثه او
اربع سنوات هنا في الولايات المتحده ولكن
لها يعني جذور من عقود اا خاصه في
الجامعات الامريكيه همم في الجامعات
الامريكيه هناك همم
فكر وحركه همم
للاصلاح الاجتماعي وللعداله الاجتماعيه
همم
المنظور لهذه الحركه هي انه الغرب وخاصه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالاضافه الى
بريطانيا
انه الدول هذه لها تاريخ سيء جدا واسود
تجاه العالم وخاصه تجاه الاقليات الموجوده
داخل المجتمعات هذه وخاصه من
السود في المجتمعات الامريكيه
واضافه الى بعض
الفئات
المجتمعات اللي لها علاقه بالجنس همم
هناك اهتمام كبير على موضوع المثليين
في الاضافه الى الاتحاد النساء وايضا
اضطهاد همم يعني فئه ظاهره اخيرا وهي
الاشخاص مثلا اشكالهم همم شكلهم بيكون ذكر
بس لكن يعتبروا نفسهم انثى فهؤلاء نسميهم
همم
همم يعني الحركه هذه حركه همم صحويه
همم حركه صحويه تعتبرها
حضرتك صحويه لانها مهتمه بموضوع العداله
الاجتماعيه وهي منظمه لها وجود اا في كل
الجامعات الامريكيه لهم مكاتب مكتب خاص
همم المكتب هذا يهتم
بارساء ونشر افكارهم وايديولوجي
الايديولوجيه حقهم وعندهم عندهم يعني
شخصيات مهمه مثل ابراهيم كاندي هذا
الاستاذ في الجامعه
كتب عن في هذا الموضوع
هل يعني حضرتك قلت لهم مؤسسه يعني لهم
عنوان لهم امم يعني ادرس محدد مسجلين
كمنظمه كحركه كمادا
الحركات يعني في بعض الحركات همم مثلا
بلاك لايف زمان حركه همم
البلاستيك
موجودين يعني
بسلوجيه هذه ظهورها همم في همم في
الجامعات او في المؤسسات الثقافيه او في
الشركات في مكاتب خاصه داخل الشركات او
داخل الجامعات وتسمى المكاتب هذه
العداله مكتب العداله والتنوع والشموع
عندنا فوق تقريبا 100 شخص
شغال في هذا المكتب همم وهم يعني دائما
همم
يطلعون الى المناهج الدراسيه الى همم
طريقه همم
العلامات العلامات الدراسيه للطلبه وهمم
وعندهم يعني افكار همم لادخال هذه
الايديولوجيه على المناهج التدريسيه على
الطريقه التعامل والعلاقه بين الاستاذ
والطالب فهم على هذا الموضوع
والمناهج الدراسيه هل هم بيفرضوا
بيتدخلوا في المناهج نفسها بالغاء او
اضافه
يدخلوا في المناهج مثلا همم ينظرون الى
الكتب التي تعين فلو مثلا كانت الكتب هذه
كلها من اشخاص يعني كنت او مؤرخين او
مفكرين
رجال بيض فيقولون ليش كلهم بيض ليش ما
تدخلون مثلا بعد الكتاب السود او بعض
الكتاب
المثليين يعني لازم حتى انه الكاتب يكون
التمثيل موضوع التمثيل مهم جدا بالنسبه
لهم فمثلا يقولون عندنا مثلا يقولون انه
همم 20% من او او 50% من الطلبه همم من
همم من
العراق الاسود او العرق او عرق معين او
كذا فلازم الاستاذ يكون من نفس العرق او
من نفس الجنس
انه ضروري انه الطالب يرى نفسه في الاستاد
من ناحيه العراقيه او من ناحيه الجنسيه
فهذه افكارهم
طب دكتور هل هي حركه همم يعني تجديديه
تنويريه وهل هي كان لها يعني ظهور قديم
يعني مثلا نقول في السبعينات او في
الستينات وام ان هذا الشيء همم جديد يعني
وفجاه ظهر اما كان له بوادر اقدم
من ناحيه الانشاء المكاتب هذه
وجود الاشخاص هذه في الجامعات وفي
المؤسسات الثقافيه ولكن لها يعني لها جذور
اديولوجيه وفكريه من همم يمكن من الستينات
من همم
السابق هي بدات اعتقد انه بدات في البدايه
مع فكره انه همم الاسود والمراه والمثلي
لازم يكون له حق لازم يكون له وجود في
الجامعه او في المؤسسات الثقافيه يعني همم
يعني في البدايه كانت موضوع التمثيل
وموضوع التمثيل الاقليات اييه هي
الظاهره ولكن الان اخذت يعني الان هي
طاغيه يعني كفكر كايديولوجيه تقضي على
الجامعات على المؤسسات الثقافيه وعلى
الشركات حتى الخاصه
والدوله الامريكيه تشجع هذا التيار وتدعم
يعني تدعم الايديولوجيا هذه
يعني
داعمه للايديولوجيا هذه نفسها باي شكل
بياتي هذا الدعم
الرئيس
مثلا الرئيس بعيدا عندما كان عليه ان
يختار همم قاضي جديد همم
للمحكمه العليا السوري في في الولايات
المتحده عاده في ال- في الماضي كان دائما
الرئيس الامريكي قبل ان يعين يقول انه
احنا همم
يعني همم
المعيار هو معيار همم
الكفاءه فقط مش اللون مش الجينز مش همم مش
ان كان يعني ذكر او انثى كذا الان هذه
التعيينها الاخير كان من البدايه قال انا
اريد ان اعين همم شخص اسود وحرمه يعني
امراه همم يعني من البدايه بغض النظر عن
عن الكفاءه فهذه يعني هذه هذه دلاله من
الدلائل الكثيره همم من الدوله الامريكيه
خاصه مع الديمقرا عند الجمهوريين همم
الافكار هذه والاديولوجيه هذه همم لن تظهر
ابدا بالعكس يعني
الحزب الجمهوري
يحاربها ظاهره ترامب اعتقد ظاهره الترامب
ادت الى همم نوع من يعني ترامب يشجع همم
ظهور هذه هذه الصحوه في امريكا وهمم
والعداء للص هو
ظهر كمان وبرغ كثير عند الجمهوريين فلنرى
مثلا الان في المستقبل يعني في الحمله
الانتخابيه القادمه على الرئاسه الامريكيه
نرى اهم شخص مثلا الان عدد ترامب يعني هو
همم
اللي هو يعني همم
فلوريدا فهو ديسنتس في في تحليلات في طرح
في افكار همم عدائي مره يعني جدا لهذه ال-
للوقت ويطرح نفسه كخيار بديل لانها لانه
معادي لافكار هذه الصحبه همم التي تركز
على التمثيل على الجنس على العرق طب السيد
ابغى اسالك بنرجع للجدر نفس الكلمه ووك
احنا اللي نعرفه اويك اللي هو استيقظه او
بحسب القاموس
البريطاني فهو عرفها كصفه اييه في البيئه
ابغى اول شيء ووك هذه هل هي يعني تاتي
بنفس المعنى من اليقظه من الصحوه ولماذا
هي مختلفه عن قويك هل هم نفس الشيء نفس
التعبير
يعني
من همم
من من اللغه الدارجه عند عند بعض السود في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فهي ليست كلمه
يعني همم
لم تكن كلمه متداوله
عند الشعب الامريكي الا كانت موجوده عند
بعض السود همم في في لغتهم الدارجه لغه
الشارع يعني همم فاخذوها هذه التعبير هذا
همم
بنوه الحركه هذه تبنت التعبير هذاك همم
اسم يعني يمثل الحركه يمثل للايديولوجيا
والحركه هذه وهي حركه يعني مهتمه بالعداله
بفكره العداله الاجتماعيه ولكن العدامه
العداله الاجتماعيه مش بالمفهوم نقول
الماركسي التقليدي اللي هو يتكلم عن
الطبقات الاجتماعيه
لا لا هم لا يتكلمون عن الطبقات
الاجتماعيه بمعنى
طبقات عامله او اكس او طبقات اقتصاديه
وانما يتكلمون عن المجتمع همم بموضوع
العرق
والاثنيه والجنس وكذا هم يعني يفرقون بين
الناس همم مش مش ك- طبقات اجتماعيه
ناس
ابغى بس نحرر شوي المفهوم
مثلا لفظه ووكس استيقظاه هذه الكلمه
فيما هناك من يعني يرجعها الى الستينات
والسبعينات في نفس البعد السياسي من من
جانب
الامريكيين السود يعني اللي همم لابعاد
نفسها قضيه يعني حقوق العرقيه والمساواه
ما بينهم ف ودي لو بايجاز تشرح لي هذا
علشان ندخل في سبب استغلال او توظيف من
جديد
من سنوات عديده يعني من قبل سنوات اربع او
خمسه سنوات
متداوله في المجتمع الامريكي او في همم في
النقب الامريكيه او في الجامعات الامريكيه
هي ظهرت همم
مع من بعد مقتل همم جورج فلويد اللي هو
همم الشخص اسود قتل من قبل الشرطه
الامريكيه بطريقه بشعه جدا همم وظهرت
وظهرت هذه الحمله من بعد مقتله همم في
الجامعه هي اعتقد الاصل همم
الكلمه هي عند المتداوله عند السود عند
بعض السود الامريكيين بمعنى ان تكون صاحي
او همم
اضطهاد ضد ضد همم السود في الولايات
المتحده يعني في المجتمع الامريكي في هناك
من دون اي شكل ضد الصوت
في كلمه اوكي يبقى معنى ان تكون واعي لهذا
الاضطهاد هذا ال همم النوع من
التصرف الموجوده
طب السيد ابغى ارجع معاك للقاموس بان مثلا
هل ممكن نقول ان الكلمه هذه تطورت من
معناها الاصلي اللي هو الاستيقاظ او هيك
الى الدعوه للعمل ومواصلات القتال من اجل
هذه يعني المبادئ اللي تندرج تحت كلمته
ووك وان يكون الفرد في حاله من الغضب
الدائم والمستمر
يعني فانه حسب قاموس اكسفورد يتحولت من
فعل ماضي استيقظه الى صفه
الى صفه والى كمان الى نعم الى صفه
لجيولوجيه معينه وهي الغضب ضد الغرب عموما
بالتاريخ الغرب الثقافه الغرب حتى انه
مثلا في بعض الجامعات ومنها جامعتي هناك
يعني
غضب او
حمله شرسه ضد تاريخ اليونان القديم تاريخ
الرومان القديم لانهم يدعون انه التاريخ
هذا تاريخ اليونان والرومان القديمه
كلاسيكي نتكلم عن 2000 سنه او اكثر انه
هذا التاريخ هذا تاريخ عنصري تاريخ عنصري
همم
المجتمع الغربي انا افكاره العنصريه على
هذا التاريخ القديم اليوناني والروماني
فلذلك همم في جامعه مثلا في بعض الاشخاص
همم
يدعمون همم يعني
الغاء
حتى تسكير كليا
هو مركز الدراسات الروماني الكلاسيكيه
اللي هي دراسه الرومانيه والاغريقيه يعني
في هناك يعني في ايديولوجيه لها على ارض
الواقع طرح
طرح لي الغاء بعد الاشخاص الغاء بعد بعد
المناهج الغاء بعد الكتب الغاء بعد
الشخصيات حتى بعد المؤسسات لانها عنصريه
يعني يدعون انها عنصريه
اثار هذه الحركه او من همم ادوار هذا
الحركه شن حرب على التاريخ نفسه
لا هو اعاده اعاده كتابه التاريخ ولكن على
كمان على ارض الواقع انا ارى مثلا من
جامعتي ومن جامعه
التاريخ امريكا
[موسيقى]
من خلال تاريخ الرقق والعباده والعبوديه
يعني همم ووجود العبيد في في امريكا همم
ففي اعاده كتاب التاريخ هلا الموضوع همم
بس همم هناك شيء مهم جدا وهو انه همم قوه
هذه الايديولوجيه وهذه الحركه همم كبيره
جدا يعني لهم سطوه لهم لهم سطوه في
المؤسسات ال- همم والجماعات الكبيره في
امريكا واثرها انه في صمت يعني انا انا
انه في خوف عند عدد كبير من ال- اساتذه او
من الطلبه من الحديث بصراحه بوضوح عن همم
عن عن بعض هذه الامور لانهم يخافون من همم
يخافون من الاشخاص هذه ويخافون من همم من
حركه همم وهي تسمى الغاء كنسليشن
يعني للمستمعين ومشاهدين يعرفوا ايش
المقصود بكنسل ايش يعني
اعطيك مثلا استاذ يكتب مقال المقال همم
يعترض لبعض اذكار او يقول انه لا بدايه
تاريخ الولايات المتحده ليس 1,600 و19
وانما 1776 ان التاريخ
انه عدد كبير من الاساتذه من الطلبه لا
يتكلمون ابدا يعني في نوع من الخوف او
الرعب الذي دخل في همم في همم عن بعض
الاشخاص وعند عدد كبير من الاشخاص عن
انتقاد خوف من انتقال هذه الحركه ومن هذه
الاتيولوجيه هذه ظاهره ظاهره الخوف من
الكلام من الكتابه هذه اول مره اراها يعني
في امريكا انا صار لي في الولايات المتحده
من
1984 يعني في الجامعات الامريكيه كطالب
وبعدين استاذ هذه اول مره يعني في ال
سنوات الاخيره هذه الثلاثه واربعه التي
ارى فيها رعب خوف عند عند الاشخاص عند
الاشخاص في الكلام بصراحه
نقدر نقول انها حركه شموليه راديكاليه
وعندها شموليه وبعدين عنيفه يعني
اتجاه اتجاه اعدائها عنيفه جدا مناظره
كذلك دكتور برنارد في هناك ايضا
هو نفس
الكانسل الكالتشر
او مختلفه
يعني في بابلك هو كمان في موضوع السوشل
ميديا يعني وجود وجود هذه مثل همم فيسبوك
فيسبوك فيسبوك
همم يعني هذه هذه
الاداه همم
للمراسله همم
من خلال الشبكه
كثير على همم بناء همم
حملات ضد بعض الاشخاص همم
الغاء الشخص والالغاء يؤدي مثلا الى همم
الفصل الفصل الشخص عن همم
في الجامعات يوضع على البلاك ليست
اول جامعه تفصل الشخص يعني تقول انه هذا
انسان عنصري نحنا نريد
فئات معينه من المجتمع ان كان السود او
المثليين او ترانس او حتى المسلمين احيانا
او
فليطرد الشخص يفصل عن عمله
اه طب استاذه الدكتور هل نقدر نعتبرها
اللغه دينيه ااا
لغه دينيه وانغلاق عقائدي مثل كالحزب
الشيوعي مثلا او المركسيه يعني
في شخص اسود امريكي اسمه
الرجل هذا الرجل الاسود
ومنتقد جدا يعني
وهو اسود همم هو يقول يعني بعد بعد
الحركه او ايديولوجيه همم
طقوس لها طقوس لها افكار لها عقيده معينه
لها عقيده لها طقوس فهي مثل الدين يعني
همم وانما ليست بيع على على
همم لاهوت معين هام لا ما عندهم يعني فكره
انه الاله اوالله ما هو مهم بل بالعكس
يعني عاده هي حركه همم تهاجم المسيحيه كان
دين عنصري
يعني لفظ او مفردات عباده همم
او اليقظه او الاستيقاظ عندهم يعني همم
عندهم ايديولوجيه وهمم ويعني اي حاجه خاصه
حركه في الحروب الثقافيه التي تجري في
امريكا الان بنسميها الكاتشربورز
[موسيقى]
امريكي
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن الحرب
الثقافيه هذه موجوده على عده همم
على مستويات مختلفه ففي حركه بين
المحافظين
همم
هذه الحروب موجوده ولها يعني بارزه على
السوشيال ميديا همم على شبكه شبكه التواصل
الامريكي وفي الصحف الامريكيه هل هناك
مثلا في الصحف الامريكيه وفي الميديا
الامريكي يعني في همم هناك البيع تايمز
الواشنطن بوست مثلا اللي هم اهم
صحيفتان في في الولايات المتحده هذه بوك
يعني هذه الصحف لها اثر كبير الوك يعني
لهم اثر كبير في على المحتوى الصحف هذه
يعني المقالات
المحافظه ضد همم
فانرى همم الانفاق نيوز مثلا اللي هي محطه
همم
تليفزيونيه ضد
الامس ام بي سي
الان اقرب للوك من همم من همم
وسام في المجتمع انقسام وهمم
وبولورازيشن نسميه بولورايزيشن بس يعني
حتى في
يعني خرق كبير في المجتمع الامريكي يعني
فيه
شديده ما
بينناب شديد في المجتمع الامريكي
يعني هذه ظاهره همم انا انا انه يعني
اصبحت يعني تزداد مع الوقت
ومخيفه للمجتماع يعني لانه المجتمع
الامريكي هناك همم يعني مسلح مجتمع مسلح
همم كما تعرفين يعني الشعب الامريكي
فانا اخاف من همم من العنف بصراحه همم من
بعد يعني بناءا على هذه اللي جاءت على هذه
الصراحه الثقافيه طيب
تعتبر
كعقيده او اشبه بدين جديد لبعض بيصفها
بانه دين اجتماعي جديد همم تدعو الى همم
هذه همم
الحركه
بس يعني ابغاه اسمح لي اقرا عليك
كانت احدى
الكاتبات المؤيدات للبوك تقول همم كنت
نائما لانواع معينه من الظلم والاضطهاد في
العالم وقد استيقظت الان على ذلك في
الواقع اعتنق العديد من الانجيليين
المحافظين تماما
ايقظ المسيحيه كطريقه لمحاربه العنصر طبعا
هنا الترجمه اعتقد انها تكون
استيقظ او استيقظت المسيحيه
كطريقه المحاربه العنصريه مستخدمينها
بالضبط بهذا المعنى شبه الدين ايقاظ ضرر
العنصريه في المجتمع واعطاء الاولويه
للنظال من اجل العداله اجتماعيه فان اغراء
الاستيقاظ يشبه الى حد بعيد اغراء الدين
من حيث انه يمكن ان يقدم ما يبدو انه
احساس عميق بالهدف والانتماء
فكثيرين من يذهب الى ان اعتبارها همم
دين اجتماعي
يعني يملا الفراغ النفسي لدى شباب الالفيه
الميلانيوم اللي يصفونهم
همم اعتقد ما بس عند الشباب شباب الالفيه
اعتقد انه في عدد كبير من البيض في امريكا
عندهم حس بالدم عندهم حيث حس انه تاريخهم
تاريخ ايه يعني همم تاريخ اتهاض ضد السود
همم وعندهم هذا الاحساس فهذا الاحساس يعني
له يعني في
حمله همم في حمله اتجاه اللي هو يعني همم
موجوده في الشوارع امريكا مثلا في شوارع
امريكا في في همم في الاماكن اللي يعني
الطبقه البرجوازيه همم
عند البيض مثلا في في مدينه مدينه جامع
فيها همم هناك يعني همم
تقريبا امام كل بيت هناك همم
علامه همم مشجعه عند البيوت كثيره من
البيض
اعتقد انه انه انه في احساس بالذنب وفي
عدد كبير من ال من الشعب الابيض
المفكر خاصه النساء
عند النساء البيض المثقفات همم في همم
يعني همم نحس كبير مع هذه الحركه مع هذه
اللي يقظه في تشجيع لها همم
موجوده يعني هذه موجوده ولكن همم من
الضروري انه ال- ال- الشاهد هنا المشاهد
للبرنامج يفهم انه بس الحركه البوك ما هي
بس همم الموضوع همم العرق وال همم
يعني العرق الاسود والاضطهاد ضدهم
والعنصاهريه وهي يعني بالاضافه الى موضوع
العنصريه في هنا في ايضا موضوع
الجنس يعني هي كمان حركه تدافع عن همم
التعدد الهويات الجنسيه
بالضبط
يعني المشاهد العالمي لم يفهمها ولكن على
ارض الواقع الظاهره هذه تعني همم
ان الرجل بامكانه ان يعتبر نفسه يعني رجل
شكلا بامكان ان يعتبر نفسه امراه وعلى
المجتمع ان يتعامل مع هذا الر- مع هذا
الشخص ليس كرجل وانما كان امراه فعندي
طلبه مثلا في الجامعه شخص
ايمان كانها يعني ذكر ولكن
يفرض ان اشير اليه كانثى
فيطلب مني مثلا انه لا اتكلم معه
واقول له وانما يفرض ان
اتكلم معه كاشي وهي الشي هذه هي يعني كانت
وليس انت وفي ايضا في ايضا انواع
اخرى يعني ما عاد تقتصر على ثلاثه انواع
في اللي غير محدد بالاساس وفي همم نعم نعم
فيخترعون يخترعون همم يعني اسماء جديده
لها لانفسهم هناك مثلا همم
اشخاص يريدون ان نتكلم معهم كذلك يعني ليس
انت او انت وانما همم
يعني المساله يعني اخذ واخراط ايضا في
تربيه الاطفال يا هذه كمان ايضا اصبحت
اشكاليه لدى المجتمع الغربي سواء في
الولايات المتحده او الاوروبي تربيه
الاطفال والزام الاباء بهذا النهج التربوي
طب ابغى اسالك ابغى اسالك هذه تحقيق
العداله الاجتماعيه استوجب الاعتراف
بحقيقه ان افراد الطبقه العامله من جميع
الاعراف يريدون نفس الحقوق او نفس الاشياء
مثلا وظائف جيده همم الرعايه الصحيه سكن
لكن رغم ذلك يعني هذه الموف من تؤثر
الحقوق في حياه السود مهمه فهل هي مشكله
في اللغه مشكله يساريه في اضطراب همم خطاب
الخطاب نفسه خطوبهم خطاب مبني على همم
الاقليات العرقيه والاقليات ال- ال-
الجنس فمثلا الفرق عنده الفقير الابيض ها
نقول رجل او عائله همم بيض همم ولو انهم
فقراء الوق يعتبرون انه هذا هذه العائله
لانهم بيض هم يمثلون
الاسياد في المجتمع يعني هم يمثلون الطبقه
الحاكمه في المجتمع ولو ولو كانوا من
الطبقه العامله فهذه عدد كبير من ال-
البيض من طبقه العمال يعني رجل اجتماعيه
العامله التقليديه التي كانت يعني
باتجاه يساري اتجاه الحزب الديمقراطي هذه
هذه المجتمعات ال- ال- البيض
الفقره كلهم الان او عدد كبير منهم همم
نجاح الى الحزب الجمهوري بسبب
سبب جماعه البوق لانه البوك لا يعترفون
بهمجماعه مظلومين
لانهم بي يعني لا يمكن ان تكون مظلوم وانت
ابيض
الابيض
بطبيعه ظالم
[موسيقى]
هل ايه
هي تنتمي الى اليسار ام ان يسار جديد همم
الليبراليين الجدد الى ماذا يعني تشوف هم
هم يمثلون اليسار المتطرف في الحزب
الديمقراطي
فان اراهم في الحزب الديمقراطي ونرى ان
الرئيس بايظن دائما في سياساته حتى
السياساتها الخارجيه اتجاه المملكه مثلا
دائما ياخذ الواقع ان الاعتبار ياخذ
ارائهم ياخذ افكارهم عن الاعتبار اعتقد
لانه
يعتقد انه الووك هم الذين همم
الاعتراف بهمم
همم
الاجنده او همم
سيؤدي الى اعطاء ايضا في الانتخابات
الصوت الاسود وصوت المراه
البيضاء المتعلمه من الطبقه الجوازيه يعني
في شرائح كبيره من المجتمع الامريكي
لان لاسباب انتخابيه لاسباب يعني
لا يعني ما هي قريبه من مبادئ اليسار
نفسها او اا يعني شذت عنه
من من اليسار بالمعنى التقليدي لليسار
اليه
العامله الاهتمام هم ليسوا يا ساليين
بمعنى
بالمعنى الاقتصادي هم هم
ليسوا ضد الرئيس
ولكن هم يريد ان يوجهوا الراسماليه
لاعطاء همم
الاقليات ال- ال- همم الافضليه
يريدون مثلا مثلا انه المجتمع الامريكي ان
يدفع الى السوق يدفع مبالغ ماليه
بسبب تاريخ الماضي بسبب الاضطهاد في
الماضي فهذه النوع من
التعويض للاضطهاد في السابق
او حركه همم
المستيقظين او المتيقظين
بانهم ما يعتبروا يسار لان اليسار هو عدد
يعني همم يعني سواء كان الماركسيه او
الشيوعيه همم بيبحث عن العداله همم
البعد الاقتصادي الاجتماعي
وهذا مخاير لدى البوك نفسها فعلشان كده هم
يقول لك لا هي ما تنتمي هي همم مثلا ابعد
من اليسار همم يعني حركه التقدمين
الا انه انه يدعي انه الطبقات الفقيره جدا
في المجتمع هي الطبقات العراقيه
الاقليات العرقيه والاقليات ال- ال- همم
الجنسيه يعني ان كان من ال- همم السود او
من همم اهل البلاد الاصليين في امريكا
يعني الهنود الحمر او
الناس اللي اصولهم من امريكا اللاتينيه
وامريكا الجنوبيه اللي هم يسمونهم
اللاتينيوس في امريكا
هم يعتبرون انه كل التعويضات وكل ال ال
الصلاحيات وكل يعني الامتيازات لازم تيجي
لهم ولا ولا تجيء للابيض
هل هناك فواصل ما بين التقدمي او
التقدميين وما بين المستيقظين او اليقضين
في يعني في في خلافات بينهم يعني مثلا في
الحزب الديمقراطي في شخص اسمه
برونيساندروس اللي هو
تقليدي يسار تقليدي كان تاريخيا دائما
يتكلم عن الطابات العامله يتكلم بطريقه
يساريه التقليديه ملكيه يعني همم اهتمامات
للطبقات الطبقيه همم وفي الواق همم
لا ما يتكلم بنفس الطريقه بس نرى انه شخص
في في الحزبده
يعني وجود الوك همش ال ال ال يعني الياسه
هذه التقليديه
اليوم
اعتقد انه غلط
بذلك نرى انه رئيس مهتم بالوك اكثر من انه
مهتم
باليسريه التقليديه يعني بعيدا لا يهتم ما
عنده يعني طرحه ما هو طرح يسار تقليدي مثل
نيسانس وانما طرح اقرب للواق فيك الشيء
اللي لفت انتباهي دكتور بان حركه الوورك
اصبح
شعاراتها وايضا اسمها
نجدها في
الشركات العالميه او البراندز المنتجات
العالميه وايضا في وزاره الدفاع او الجيش
رغم ان هي بتهاجم مثلا الشرطه ومن حملتها
يعني
واضافه الى هذا انها تختلف عن اليسار في
هذا الاطار يعني بانها مؤيده للكابتلزم
للراسماليه بحيث انها
مؤيده او بالاحرى الاسماء تحاول ان تستقبل
الورق يعني
وتدعي انها همم وتبني يعني تبني همم
يعني كل عملها على على هذا الفكر فالان
مثلا في كل الشركات الامريكيه ضروري من
ضروري ان همم همم
المجلس الاداري للشركه ان يكون ع- في
تمثيل لكل الفئات الامريكيه همم وانا ممكن
انه مثلا مجلس اداري عن
يعطى الاحترام ان لم يجد عليه ما بس همم
نساء ولكن ايضا سود وهمم وناس من اللاتيني
الى اخره
فاصبح هذا التمثيل يعني هو قريب جدا
بصراحه من همم
حتى يعني من
النظام المذهبي في لبنان مثلا في لبنان
دائما في تمثيل
المسيحيين والسنه والشيعه وكذا وكل يعني
كل كل
مكتب اداري كل مكتب حكومي لازم يكون في
التمثيل هذا على بناء على الدين نفس الشيء
ولكن في امريكا مبني على العرق وعلى الجلد
في العالم العربي
عربيه في الخارج للقضايا مثلا النفطه
والموقف من ايران او قضايا المناخ
على المجتمعات الغربيه الاخرى اننا مثلا
في بريطانيا في حركه مثل الحركه
موجوده في بريطانيا
التاثير انا لم ارى همم يعني حركه مماثله
لها في العالم العربي وانما التيار هذا
داخل المجتمعات الغربيه ان كانت امريكيه
او بريطانيه او فرنسيه
يعني تضغط على القاده السياسيين في
سياساتهم الخارجيه فا
مثلا الوك جماعه البوك الموجودين في اول
المحببين للجوكر الموجودين في الكونجرس
الامريكي في المجلس الشورى الامريكي
يضغطون على على الرئيس يعني لهم تاثير على
الرئيس فايدل من اتجاه ااه
سياسه السياسه الامريكيه همم تجاه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه او في موضوع المناخ
التغيير المناخي يعني لهم اجنده معينه همم
خارجيه همم لانهم معاذين للسياسه
التقليديه او سياسه سياسه التقليديه
الامريكيه فهم يعتبرون انه امريكا تقليديا
الدوله الامبرياليه فهم كل حلفاء امريكا
التقليديين لمنهم السعوديه مثلا همم هم
اعداء هذه الحالات يعني يعادون الحلفاء
التقليديين لام لانهم جزء من منظومه
الهيمنه الامريكيه على العالم هذا في هذا
في تعبير هموم يعني في تحليلاتهم
همم ابغى اسالك استاذ تحت مظلات ووك شل
الشعارات او الليبلز اللي همم بتكون تحت
هذا المظله مثلا في عندنا شعار ان
ابولوجيسي كول مي وفي ايضا بوليتيكل كوريك
همم كوريكتس اي ثنك انها كده همم
هذه المفردات
يعني تعبير امريكي بمعنى انه الشخص يتكلم
همم سياسيه همم بطريقه يعني همم مقبوله
اللي هي اللي هي مثلا ضد العنصريه او مع
حقوق المراه يعني كل الكلام التقدممي
السياسي ان همم نعمبرع عن شخص احيانا
الشخص هذا يقال عنه انه
سياسيه همم
يعني كلامه صحيح
فهذه ظاهره في امريكا في امريكا الان في
ظاهرا سميها
اللي هي انه الواحد بيعبر عن افكار مش
بالضروره يكون هو مقتنع فيها ولكن تعبر عن
مواقف الووك او مواقف اليسار التقدميه
من خلال من تعبير هذا همم
يعني همم صيط الشخص رؤيه الناس للشخص
تتحسن لانه همم
يبين نفسه كانها تقدمه كانها يعني مع
الموجه الموجه هذه اللي هي الان يعني همم
موضه في امريكا الان في موضه يعني الافكار
مثل
احيانا الافكار لها موضه يعني انه الان
الوقت هي ال- الموضه الاخيره يعني الصرع
على الاخيره في امريكا
وان ابو لوجيتك مي هذا بمعنى انه انا اللي
افهم انه الشخص اللي يقول يتكلم بالطريقه
هذه انه يتكلم بصراحه من مطلقه بيتكلم عن
الحقيقه المطلقه انه امريكا بلد عنصري
امريكا التاريخي عن سوري وانا لا لا يعني
لا
اعتذر عن الفكر هذا
يعني في هناك استخدام لها مثلا اذا كانت
بلاك ومن همم او انها مثلا مثلا سمينه او
انها كذا يعني اخرجوا هذا الشعار ان انا
لا اعتذر عن نفسي يعني او اعتذر عن ما
اكون انا عليه حتى حتى السمن ها حتى كمان
لها دخل
في وزن الشخص يعني ههه
ايه اكيد اكيد انه اي اي عنصريه او اي
اضطهاد ضد الشخص الثمين اللي هو اللي هو
يعني الناصح هذا يعتبر نوع من الاضطهاد ال
ال ال ال الانسان الثمين كمان بايعتذر عن
سنه لان هو هذه طبيعه
يعني اخترعت او خلقت معجم لغوي جديد
مفردات جديد لان تسمح لي اقول لك مثلا همم
سمعت هناك في مخططات المنازل ما يعرف
بالماستر الروم همم وهي غرفه النوم
الرئيسيه بترجمتها العربي قالبه بتغيير
كلمه وجمله ماسروم الى من روم الى هذه
الدرجه اصبحوا يتدخلوا يعني في تفاصيل
المفردات
يتدخلون في الكلام في التعبير في الكلام
همم مثلا جامعه
الاسبوع
يعني ورقه عن الكلمات المقوله والكلمات
الغير مقبوله فالكلام من الكلمات الغير
مقبوله امريكا يعني الكلمه الامريكي غير
مقبول لانها كلمه عنصريه بالنسبه لهم اصل
كلمه تعود الى شخص ابيض من اصول ايطاليه
اسمه امريكيه فلذلك الكلمه غير مقبوله
يعني يتدخلوا في الكلام ان كان ماستر
بيتجروم او يعني لانها يعني غرفه السيد هو
ال ال الذي يستعبد العبيد
يتدخلون كمان يعني حتى اعتقد انه ما بس في
الكلام حتى
تصرف الناس يختلف الان خاصه في الجامعات
وفي همم في الاماكن الثقافيه يعني
الامريكيه اختلفت همم
التعامل بين الاشخاص في خوف من الك من همم
خلق عداء او جرح المشاعر الاخر همم يعني
حتى في الصف مثلا في الصف انا اذا اذا
عندي مثل ما قال همم
انه ال- ال- الطلبه يقراونها وفي المقاله
هذه ما هي انا مش كاتبها شخص اخر
المكاتبها نقول من 100 سنه لازم فسر
الطلبه انه هذه المقاله يمكن تجرح همم
مشاعركم يمكن تجرحكم فانا لا فانا احذركم
قبل قراءه المقاله انه فيها همم فيها شيء
يمكن يزعجكم واذا ازعجكم هذا الشيء همم
اطلب منكم انه لا تقراونه
يعني صار المجتمع صار خايف من الاستاذ
يخاف من الطالب الطالب يخاف من الاستاذ
يعني
مشاكل كثيره في المجتمع
يعني حديث لكنها يعني قد يعني نجى يعني ان
هذه الحركه بالفعل اشبه ما تكون بين
اجتماعي جديد همم
طبعا في كثير من كتبوا في هذا ومن هم مع
الوك بان هذا دين اكثر واقعيه واكثر
التسامح مع المعطيات العصريه في في الوقت
الراهن بعيدا عن همم يعني الاديان الاخرى
التي قد تكون متشدده او صارمه في بعض
الجوانب
انا انا حركه الواو وايديولوجيه الواوك
انها حرب على
المجتمع والتاريخ الامريكي
التقليدي وهي حرب على
المسيحيه يعني الدين المسيحي التقليدي
ومن بعد ذلك سينتقل للعداء الى الديانات
الاخرى ان كانت اليهوديه اول اول
الدين الاسلامي يعني هي هي
حركه غذائيه لكل القيم التقليديه القيم
المحافظه وعلى
على تاريخ الدوله الامريكيه وعلى تاريخ
الحضاره الغربيه عموما
اسم اسم محاربه العنصريه
هل هي قابله للتصدير في مجتمعاتنا في
الشرق في الشرق الاوسط في الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه وشو مستقبلها
المجتمعات الغربيه الاخرى المجتمعات ال ال
العربيه والاسلاميه من صعب ان تصدر اليها
لانها مجتمعات محافظات ومتديين فاني حركه
يعني في صميمها هذه حركه معاديه لكل القيم
التقليديه الدينيه منها قيمه دين الاسلام
فانا لا انه لا ارى انه اي همم
يعني همم بين شخص محافظ ازاي يرى فيها الا
يعني اشياء سلبيه جدا
طب اسمح لي نتوقف عند هذه النقطه استاذ
دكتور
اختم معك حلقتنا واقول لنا جاءت استيقظ
قويك فلاهوت التحرير المسيحي اما متيقظ
ووك ففي الايديولوجيا تقدميه ونتساءل هنا
هل نحن امام خصائص اصوليه وعقيده شموليه
منافسه اشبه ما تكون بدين جديد ام في ذلك
مبالغه هذا جماعات وانا هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]